c'est un rapport presque guerrier à la
nourriture c'est à dire on est toujours
en combat je passais mon temps à me
trouver de plus en plus gros alors que
j'étais de plus en plus maigres
j'aimerais que ça rejoint une forme de
une forme de honte la première qui est
déjà
la honte d'avoir une maladie mentale
donc déjà le fait de l'avouer à laquelle
s'ajoute en fait la honte d'être victime
d'une maladie féminine bien que je pense
qu'il ya énormément de d'hommes de plus
en plus qui sont atteintes d'anorexie
[Musique]
avant tout c'était un plaisir le
football c'est à dire j'ai commencé très
jeune j'ai commencé à 3 4 ans jusqu'à
arriver au stade lavallois au centre de
formation du stade lavallois qui à
l'époque était et est un club en ligue 2
je fais du football un des piliers de ma
vie c'est à dire que
le mois d'août je sais tous les mois de
l'année où je serai je serais parti à
lorient je serais parti à rennes je
serais parti à nantes finalement c'est
un équilibre et les éducateurs du club
font le choix de ne pas me conserver et
au même moment finalement j'ai le jeu
connaît le premier décès
gérer important de ma vie qui est
qu'elle décède ma tante et ses deux
choses là finalement on revienne en
effet boomerang c'est là qu'on commence
à rechercher de la maîtrise du jeu
m'entraînais deux fois plus j'ai
commencé à faire attention à mon
alimentation et en fait cette attention
à l'alimentation est devenu une
obsession cette maîtrise est devenue une
emprise et là j'ai commencé je te
mangerais ram écroulé petit à petit dans
cet escalier infernal de la maladie est
là donc c'est moins d'alimentation c'est
plus de sport et finalement les bilans
et la perte de poids derrière est énorme
quoi c'est à dire que moi j'ai toujours
tourné notamment quand je te sens une
formation entre 62 63 kg et moi je me
suis pour jouer sur ma vitesse
finalement perdre un peu de poids ça
peut m'aider mais en fait je suis passé
de 63 kg finalement qu'on va partir et
après on arrive à 60 c'est pas trop mal
puis puis on descend à 58 puis on
descend 55 53 50 et je suis descendu
jusqu'à 46 kg pour 1 mètre 80 kw à la
vision en fait les militaires très cadré
très maîtrisée ça commençait le matin
par gérer le petit déjeuner toujours
prendre un grand verre d'eau pour
essayer d'une certaine manière de
regonfler l'estomac on va au lycée à
pied on suit les cours on retient pas
grand chose parce que finalement on a pu
les capacités intellectuelles pour
retenir ces choses là sont très irrités
durant les phases d'anorexie et on a
envie d'envoyer chier tout le monde
mangeait quasiment pas le midi et en
fait essayer de faire croire le soir en
aux parents qu'on mange normalement ça
passe toujours par des stratégies de
compensatoires comme ça et aller se
coucher et dormir relativement peu parce
qu'on n'a pas suffisamment l'énergie
pour dormir et ça passe par énormément
nuit blanche ce qui nous rend encore
plus irritable et tout ça c'est un cycle
un cycle infernal quoi et moi je
compensais cette prise alimentaire par
une pratique vraiment excessive du sport
donc c'est j'avais entraînements tous
les soirs le week-end je monte les
escaliers 100 x 200 x jusqu'à mende
déchirer les mollets c'est vraiment une
chute en a vendu corps dans cette
dépendance la cua mais on le voit petit
à petit en fait que nous on devient un
fantôme mais c'est peut-être aussi un
signal d'alarmé quand voit notre corps
finalement aux autres l'arrêt dit rien
de plus visible qu'un corps humain est
un corps humain totalement flétri comme
ça ne peut être qu'un signal d'alarmé et
je pense que tous les signaux en fête où
tous les regards alentours convergent
vers nous j'aimerais que ça rejoint une
forme de une forme de honte la première
qui est déjà
la honte d'avoir une maladie mentale
donc déjà le fait de l'avouer à laquelle
s'ajoute en fait la honte d'être victime
d'une maladie féminine moi je ne ressens
pas personnellement parce que j'ai pas
une vision genre et notamment de cette
maladie là les retours qui en souffre
est effectivement m j'aimerais mettre
toujours que c'est une maladie qui
atteint beaucoup plus les femmes bien
que je pense qu'il ya énormément de
d'hommes de plus en plus qui sont
atteintes d'anorexie que ce soit par les
injonctions de la société les
injonctions gerra avoir un corps sain à
la salle de sport etc ou petit à petit
se développent ces choses là après je
pense que dans beaucoup de cas aussi on
cache l'anorexie derrière la performance
ça il faut s'en méfier notamment dans
les milieux sportifs moi j'avais décidé
de parler
peut-être égoïstement au début
pour ma gueule
parce que ça me permettait en fait de
m'en sortir ça me permettait toujours
cet ennemi à abattre qui est l anorexie
en fait derrière je voulais sortir un
témoignage dans le sens où finalement
j'étais abattu et je peux montrer que
j'ai réussi quelque chose qui est ce
passage de l'anorexie finalement à la
vie de nouveau et peut-être aussi un
message d'espoir j'irai pour les autres
là je viens d'accompagner en fait une
jeune fille qui a aussi écrit son son
livre et je voulais vraiment l'encouragé
dans ce processus là parce que elles
aussi sont les sorties et
en fait c'est des petites victoires mais
c'est des victoires qui sont hyper
importante pour nous quoi